schau mal nach baden württemberg einen
großbrand im kleinen hoberg am rande des
schwarzwald da hat ein ganzer sie sehen
hier die bilder straßenzug die brand
sieben häuser in diesen kleinen dorf in
flammen die gute nachricht es gibt keine
verletzten aber es ist ein riesiges
flammen drama dort in diesem ortsteil
nur 1700 einwohner da kennt jeder jeden
jeder kennt jemanden der er dieses haus
oder ein anderes betroffenes haus sein
zuhause nennt ja quasi ganzes dorf in
flammen da heute am rande des
schwarzwalds unserer reporter sascha
baumann ist genau dort denn wir fragen
uns die ganzen tag wie kann das
passieren hat das einfach so lange
gedauert bis die feuerwehr dort war oder
was ist der grund dafür dass ein ganzer
straßenzug altes dorf brennt
also die feuerwehr trifft an diesem
inferno sicher keine schuld sie war mit
einem großaufgebot vor ort teilweise
zeitweise über 180 einsatzkräfte mir hat
vorhin der einsatzleiter erklärt er habe
schon auf der anfahrt weitere kräfte
hinzu alarmiert als klar war dass es so
ein großes feuer hier gibt die polizei
und sachverständige sind im moment dabei
die brandursache schon einmal zu
eruieren die polizei hat vor wenigen
minuten mitgeteilt man habe bereits
einen ersten hinweis das feuer könnte im
bereich eines carports entstanden sein
inwieweit dort ein fahrzeug geparkt war
ist momentan nicht klar von dort aus ist
dann das feuer durch das gebäude
gewandert und dann von dachstuhl zu
dachstuhl man sieht das vielleicht etwas
im hintergrund
dies ist eine sehr sehr enge bebauung
wand an wand giebel an giebel gebäude an
gebäude
es war sozusagen glück dass die
feuerwehr das den brunch toppen konnte
dass es nur sieben gebäude sind es gebe
sollten wir der einsatzzeit holen
berichtet durchaus noch mehr häuser die
hätten betroffen sein können insofern
also die feuerwehr hat hier ihr
möglichstes geleistet sascha die häuser
die wir sehen sind ein zuhause von
menschen die jetzt nicht wissen wohin
beschreibe uns einmal wie das dorf mit
diesem drama umgeht und wie es den
menschen geht die diese häuser bewohnt
haben
also das sagt dass das folgen schon es
ist ein kleines dorf 1700 einwohner hier
hilft natürlich jeder jedem die meisten
der bewohner sind bei freunden bei
verwandten untergekommen und haben
zumindest jetzt wieder ein dach über dem
kopf aber eines ist auch klar sie haben
alles verloren wenn wir die gebäude
hinter mir anschauen da ist nicht mehr
viel übrig was nicht durch das feuer
zerstört wurde wurde spätestens durch
das löschwasser und rauch bar gemacht
das heißt alle
erinnerungen fotos all das was wir zu
hause haben was wir gern haben haben die
menschen hier in diersburg verloren ein
dorf in flammen dort sascha baumann
unser bild reporter berichtet von der
ort lasst uns wissen was wir für die
menschen dort am rande des schwarzwalds
tun können das ist wirklich ein
besonders bewegendes feuerdrama dauert
heute dass ich ja abgespielt hat in den
vergangenen stunden danke dir
[Musik]